y voy a hacer algunos ejemplos más de
problemas que puedan encontrar las
medidas de ciertos ángulos vamos a
empezar con este problema de aquí que
nos dice que la medida del ángulo mayor
de un triángulo es cuatro veces la
medida del segundo ángulo mayor como
tercer dato nos dice que el ángulo menor
es de 10 grados y a partir de esta
información nos pregunta cuáles son las
medidas de todos los ángulos del
triángulo les voy a dibujar nuestro
triángulo para pasar las hipótesis por
acá supongamos que el triángulo es este
de acá sabemos que el ángulo más
chiquito mide 10 grados lo voy a pintar
por aquí para marcar que mide 10 grados
y ahora tenemos que ponerle algún nombre
al ángulo mediano voy a llamar al ángulo
mediano x no voy a poner por acá es
decir que x es igual al ángulo mediano
lo copió en el dibujo y la primera parte
del problema nos da la información de
que el ángulo más grande mide 4 veces el
ángulo mediano entonces voy a copiar
esto ahora en el dibujo por acá
bueno marcamos la información con azul
entonces si la medida del mediano es x
la medida de más grandes 4x y entonces
es un buen momento para recordar que las
medidas de los ángulos de un triángulo
suman 180 grados entonces tenemos una
ecuación que nos dice que 4x más x más
la medida del más chiquito que es 10 más
10 grados es igual a 180 grados
lo ponemos por acá 180 grados y con esto
ya podemos trabajar con la ecuación 4x
con x nos da 5 x el 10 lo copiamos igual
y eso de ahí debe ser igual a 180 grados
entonces restamos desde ambos lados nos
queda 5x igual a 170 ahora vamos a
dividir esto entre entre 5 en 3 x es
igual a 170 entre sí
cuanto nos da 170 entre 5 creo que nos
da 34 lo voy a hacer por acá a ver voy a
hacer la división pero si debería ser 34
porque en 150 cabe 30 veces y además de
eso nos quedan otros 20 en los cuales
cabe cuatro veces y entonces debería de
dar 34 pero hacemos la división de todas
formas a ver 170 entre 5 primero tomamos
10 y 75 cabe tres veces 5 por 3 al 15
restamos aquí nos queda 2 baja el 0
ahora el 5 cabe cuatro veces en 20 4 por
5 nos da 20 restamos 20 con 20 nos queda
0 ya no hay residuos entonces si nos da
34 la medida x es 34 entonces el ángulo
mediano mide 34 y así el ángulo más
grandote 4 por 34 verdad entonces 4 por
34 4 por 4 nos da 16 4 por 30 a 120 nos
da 102 a 136 grados a ver déjenme
checarlo es 4 por 4 16 luego 4 por 30 y
120 entonces de 120 más 16 136 entonces
ahí están las medidas de los ángulos del
triángulo nos quedan 10 grados 34 grados
y 136 grados vamos a hacer un ejemplo
más
bajar aquí y aquí tenemos un dibujo más
entonces lo que quiero hacer en este
problema digo hay muchas cosas que se
pueden pedir en este dibujo pero lo que
quiero hacer es encontrar la medida de x
y de estos dos ángulos marcados el de 4x
y el de 2x entonces vamos a vamos a
encontrar ciertas cosas del dibujo vamos
a encontrar unas paralelas y con eso
vamos a resolver el problema la cosa que
tenemos es que este esta recta la ave es
paralela al ac ahí está marcada que
tienen la misma dirección está un poco
marcado artesanalmente verdad pero pues
tenemos que utilizar esa información
entonces vamos a aprovechar esa
información y pues ya abajo que tenemos
paralelas pues como que tiene que tener
que ver con líneas transversales con
ángulos internos o tal vez con
triángulos verdad pero hay que tener
cuidado con estos dos ángulos de aquí
estos dos ángulos podrían parecer
iguales pero no lo son porque estas
líneas no son la misma esta línea de
hecho se enchufa acá aquí verdad
entonces no podemos suponer esto déjenme
borrarlo entre la cosa interesante del
dibujo
es de poder leer bien los ángulos
internos que se forman con estas rectas
paralelas entonces voy a prolongar estos
dos segmentos para cada para allá y
entonces ya se parece un poco más a los
ejemplos que habíamos visto con rectas
paralelas y también vamos a prolongar el
segmento bc para alargarlo y ver qué nos
pasa para ver qué nos pasa con los
ángulos lo voy a seguir trazando por acá
entonces esto de aquí es una transversal
de esas dos rectas paralelas que
prolongamos entonces este ángulo de acá
que mide 4x debe tener un ángulo
correspondiente como casi todo el
trabajo en estos problemas consiste en
encontrar cuáles son los ángulos
internos correspondientes en las
transversales y todo eso pues vamos a
marcar muy bien este segmento el
segmento bc para marcar muy bien la
transversal también vamos a marcar muy
bien nuestras rectas paralelas las voy a
remarcar aquí con color verde y entonces
ya remarcadas bien estas dos rectas
podemos pasar este ángulo de 4x algún
lado acá al lado derecho con la otra
paralela
estoy acá también va a ser 4x déjenme
pintarlo con el mismo color amarillo que
el del lado izquierdo para que nos quede
bien claro que me dé lo mismo es decir
4x entonces este acá también debe ser 3x
y llevamos súper bien
stang lo de 4x y este ángulo de 2x son
adyacentes y además forman parte de una
misma línea entonces son suplementarios
esto ya nos da información numérica del
problema porque pues como están cuando
como están hechas entes y hacen una
línea las medidas de estos dos ángulos
deben de sumar 180 grados
entonces déjenme pasar esto por acá 4x
con 2x nos debe dar igual a 180 grados
entonces 6x nos lleva igual a 180 grados
y dividiendo entre 6 nos queda que x es
igual es igual a 30 grados y entonces x
es igual a 30 grados sale entonces ahora
calculando este ángulo de acá es 2 veces
x entonces 2 por 30 que vale 60 lo voy a
escribir aquí vale 60 grados y el otro
ángulo que mide 4 x es 4x o sea 4 por 34
por 30 nos da 120 grados
y listo calculamos los ángulos que
queríamos